all right tonight major major progress
on three big fronts especially with the
President and North Korea and the
negotiations the June 12 summit is back
now only hours ago a top lieutenant from
North Korea named kim yeongcheol hand
delivered a personal note to kim jong-un
to president Trump and according to The
Wall Street Journal this note was
described as fairly basic but reportedly
expressed Kim jong-un's interest in
holding the nuclear summit earlier today
here is how the president reacted let's
take a look the meeting on June 12th and
Singapore what very well it's really it
gets to know you kind of a situation
Mike has spent two days doing this we've
gotten to know their people very well
and we will you people are gonna have to
travel because you'll be in Singapore or
June 12 and I think it'll be a process
it's not I never said it goes in one
meeting I think it's gonna be a process
but the relationships are building and
that's a very positive talking about
years of hostility years of problems is
a really hatred between so many
different nations but I think you're
gonna have a very positive result in the
end not from one meeting we're not gonna
sign it what I'm gonna go in and sign
something on June 12th we never work
we're going to start a process and I
told them today take your time you can
go fast when you go slowly but I think
they'd like to see something happen and
if we can work that out that are
beginning
yeah I do think so he'd like to see it
happen he wants to be careful he wants
to be you know he's not gonna run and do
things all right that's the president
great news by the way for the entire
world
and look at what we've won so far now
the president scheduled to hold a series
of weekend briefings at Camp David about
this upcoming summit where the United
States plans to negotiate the complete
the unilateral D nuclearization of North
Korea and the Korean Peninsula amazing
news for the world
there's promise there's hope and by the
way your media said would never happen
we're gonna have a lot more on this
later in the show tonight but first huge
massive news on the economic front the
economy in the United States is now
booming officially we are breaking
records month after month in May a
robust 223,000 jobs were added the
unemployment rate in the United States
is now at an 18-year low jobless claims
dropping to three point eight percent
in fact we've only seen a number that
low since 1969 the Mets won the World
Series and get this african-american
unemployment also at an all-time low for
the first time five point nine percent
consumer confidence at a 17-year high
look at that headline from the New York
Times this had to kill them we ran out
of words to describe how good the job
numbers are now the president's economic
agenda is clearly succeeding and despite
what the destroyed Trump media tells you
night after night after night this
country is in a so much better place
more prosperous place with President
Trump at the helm numbers do not lie
let's take a trip down memory lane and
contrast with this with President
Obama's horrific economic track record
it's a virtually no growth record high
distribution of food stamps 13 million
more Americans were on food stamps 8
million more Americans were in poverty
we had the lowest labor participation
rate since the 70s the worst
homeownership rate in 51 years the worst
recovery since the 40s and he doubled
the national debt yeah that was Barack
Obama's record we'll get back to all
this major news on the economic front
later in the show but now we got to turn
to some other breaking news tonight
and this is huge from John Solomon his
brand-new bombshell report the FBI's
efforts to monitor the Trump campaign
actually originated months before the
FBI authorized the counterintelligence
investigation into so-called Russian
election and appearance this after quote
foreign figures contacted Trump campaign
advisers and provided the FBI with
hearsay allegations of Trump Russia
collusion according to John Solomon
these foreign figures including some of
the trusted intelligence sources and
even some Hillary Clinton supporters in
other words what this means is members
of the deep state that upper echelon
that we talked about Clinton sycophants
they were literally flooding the FBI
with lies unverified uncorroborated
corroborated anti Trump material and
there's more remember the lovebirds
struck in Page John Solomon tonight has
uncovered a series of new texts from
these two anti Trump FBI officials that
show the Obama administration was likely
involved in steering this investigation
against the Trump campaign including one
text that took place as the FBI was
opening their investigation into
so-called Russian meddling where Lisa
page writes quote we're not going to
withstand the pressure soon and then
page and struck also expressing fears
that Obama would quote hijack their
investigation or leaked details to the
press and in another text from Peter
struck he indicated that the Obama
administration was very much involved in
the FBI investigation writing quote the
White House
meaning the Obama White House is running
this so what did Obama know when did he
know it what did it his inner circle
know when did they know it it's now time
to put the former president and his
entire team under oath now Sarah Carter
also tonight another new report and
bombshell detailing the possible
connection between an international
spying alliance called the five eyes you
can't put this at a novel and the
rampant surveillance of the Trump
campaign it's even bigger than we
thought after all a Solomon and Carter
both reported the investigation into
Trump Russia collusion remember it
jaded abroad in London now the United
Kingdom is a key member of this five
eyes alliance and despite all of this
you got the lunatic former communist
former CIA director under Obama John
Brennan now calling President Trump
paranoid for expressing concerns over
deep state spying we already know it's
true how could it be paranoid
sounds like he's very defensive take a
look I think the mr. Trump has
demonstrated a paranoia and insecurity
as well as a real concern about the
investigation that is underway certainly
his tweets do not seem like they're
coming from a person of innocence and
confidence mr. Trump is going to promote
his narrative he certainly is going to
continue to try to discredit the FBI and
the CIA and others but I think make no
mistake about it the American justice
system I think is going to prevail in
this endeavor to get to the bottom of
who might have been collaborating and
working with foreign actors to try to
undermine the integrity of the election
all right remember this is the same John
Brennan who went on national TV a few
months ago and told the world that
Donald Trump should be very very worried
sounds like a deep state threat
take a listen I think he's afraid of the
President of Russia why well I think one
could speculate as to why that the
Russians may have something on him
personally that they could always roll
out and make his life more difficult
clearly I think it's important for us to
be able to improve relations with Russia
but the fact that he has has had this
fawning attitude toward mr. Putin has
not said anything negative about him I
think continues to you know say to me
that he does have something to fear all
right putting John Brennan's blind
contempt and hatred for president Trump
aside we have even more revelations to
bring you showing that the deep state is
starting to crack according to a new
report The Wall Street Journal's
chemstro so there are now serious issues
with the FBI's quote Papadopoulos with
nobody ever heard of and that narrative
after the alleged informant in the case
publicly contradicted the FBI's own
claims that the one-time low-level Trump
adviser discussed the hacked Democratic
emails and
remember the now-infamous 2016 trump
tower meeting between Donald Trump jr.
Russian lawyer a Russian American
lobbyist and a few others oh we have new
information recently unearthed the
transcript from a 2017 Senate hearing
that the Russian American lobbyists
admitted to personally knowing Hillary
Clinton and some of the people who
worked in her campaign so what was
someone who knew Hillary Clinton doing
in that meeting was the media gonna
report on that it's unbelievable it's
more insane every day we'll have more on
this also later in the show also tonight
let's turn to the Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosen Stein you know the guy
that said Comey should be fired the guy
that signed the last VISAA warrant based
on the phony dossier the Clinton bought
and paid for
she used the foreign agent to put
together funneling money through a law
firm then to GPS then to the foreign
agent Russian lies Russian government
lies to manipulate you the American
people last night we showed you how to
rose enstein clear conflicts of interest
surrounding this ongoing Russian probe
specifically you know his key role in
firing Comey he's witnessed a in that
whole investigation and he's the one
that appointed Muller now finally people
in DC are getting what we have been
telling you there are growing calls
tonight for a-rod Rosenstein to recuse
himself that includes Senator Lindsey
Graham
welcome aboard senator he is asking
three very important questions quote do
you consider yourself a potential
witness in the Muller investigation
regarding the firing of director Comey
by President Trump if not why not he
recommended it yeah he's a witness and
if so by the way you should recuse
yourself from further interactions with
oversight of the Muller investigation
thankfully finally someone saying what
we have been saying and calling for over
and over for months the Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein it's time for you
to answer those questions we know the
answers and then recuse yourself and get
out of the way because you are the most
conflicted person in all of this not the
Attorney General jeff Sessions and by
the way great news for me tonight pay
close attention
remember when Senator Chuck Schumer said
that you better not mess with
Intel community because they gonna get
you six ways to Sunday this is great
news for me that's selling off there
jerome corsi he's the author of this
book it's out now bookstores on
amazon.com barnesandnoble.com it's
called killing the deep state you might
remember him he was back remember the
group against john kerry vietnam vets
for truth he was one of them he's saying
that yours truly that i sean hannity and
the next target of the deep state wow
isn't it so great to know that these
corrupt officials with their backs
against the wall that are desperate
desperate people do desperate things the
people that have the most powerful tools
of intelligence and now going after me
okay really so sadly after all we have
learned you know now we have jerome
Coors ease prediction it doesn't
surprise me isn't that sad are we the
United States of America are we gonna be
the former Soviet Union or are we gonna
be Venezuela I promise you this one
thing
I'm never stopping ever